[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
saw a picture of brian cranston he was
playing softball over the weekend and i
went oh my god what happened to brian
cranston
he let himself go
you guys saw the picture let's take a
guess did brian cranston is he on hard
times did he let himself go or is this a
role
todd i'm going to start with you i gave
it some thought and i put down a
frustrated long time college professor
slowly going insane realizing he's been
wasting his time today's students simply
don't want to learn anything new they
just want their degree in a six figure
job expected to be waiting for them as
soon as they graduate you gave this a
lot a lot of thought set no connor i
gave it much less thought and it's much
more superficial okay i think he's uh
it's like a post-retirement david
letterman
oh oh
oh he's gonna play letterman yeah
post-retirement when he grew the beard
out all right marv
i gave it little thought too i was gonna
say mark david chapman current day and
kind of talk about what went into the
john lennon murder damn
paulie even less thought unit bomber too
okay
let's bring in brian cranston the great
actor
who joins us now um how would you
describe your look there brian
[Laughter]
well uh dp i'd probably describe it as
an old lion being eaten by jackals
uh
i i uh
you know thanks for all those uh
unabomber and david letterman uh yeah
things um no i i am doing a show i'm
doing a show actually i'm i'm in uh
really good shape i had to i dropped a
lot of weight i'm uh now at 169
for my 511 height and my
nutritionist says uh i'm still gaining
in muscle so hey at 66 man i can't argue
with that okay so what's the role you're
playing
i can't tell you that
uh i it's it's a little bit of a secret
is this the better call saul appearance
no
have you already shot that
yeah we already shot oh okay
aaron paul and i were whisked away in
the the darkness of night
truly uh flown in secretly yeah got into
an suv driven to
an airbnb
and told we can't leave he had the upper
unit i had the bottom unit and it was
like that's it we stayed there for four
days with the exception of sneaking off
to the stage
to shoot our uh our scene
why the secrecy
well because you you know i guess they
they just didn't want it to get out you
know you want you want it to be nice
surprises then all of a sudden uh
we heard our the executive producers
just saying yeah they're going to be
oh i guess we can let this out
what role
do you play
in the role that you'll play in in this
cameo
like are you allowed to say to vince
gilligan
what about this
i i play the role of walter white in the
no no no but you're
the input of being walter you know what
i'm talking about i know what you're
talking about no with someone like vince
gilligan or peter gould who co-ep
uh better call saul you i mean you just
have complete trust in them you know you
just say
where do you want me to go i'll show up
whenever you want and and they protect
the characters and the storyline so well
that
you're you don't have to ask those
questions just do what they ask how hard
is it to get back into that character
you know it was a little interesting but
once
you know i mean it's like if you sit in
behind that microphone with all your
you know your your uh action figures and
and play dolls there you know you you
sit back there and all of a sudden you
go oh i know this i i know i know where
i am
and uh and you just you feel at home but
i'm not acting like a great radio host i
am a great radio host there's a
difference
well there's one adjective that might be
replaced in that sentence
um i'm you know i'm i'm not one to say
you know might be superlative
okay so
a good radio host well it might even be
better than great i'm not saying one way
or the other i'm not committing
when does this episode come out
you know i don't even know
is that a secret as well no it's not
okay
because we
we had to go when both aaron and i were
free in our schedules and that was april
of 2021
so we were in for four days and because
we shot everything out of sequence i i
don't even know what episode it was that
we were in i don't remember
when did you guys decide that you wanted
to go into the tequila business or
mescal
we're in the mezcal business it was
three years after the end of breaking
bad
we
didn't see much of each other for those
three years because you know your life
happens you go your own way
and we were at a sushi bar in new york
city and and we said man i miss you i
know what what can we do and this is the
difference between men and women women
are so much smarter they say i miss you
let's get together and have dinner and
things like that but men we go oh we got
to have we got to play golf we got to do
tennis or we have we have to have a
business together we we can't just see
see each other so we started a business
together because we wanted to spend more
time with each other
and and but we're glad we did because
dos hombres is just crushing it good for
you
uh we're talking to brian cranston he's
in uh jerry and uh jerry and marge go
large that's on paramount plus with uh
annette benning
yeah
it's actually uh an an uh uplifting
story right you know it's just this is
the the movie that i wanted to do coming
out of the lockdown
i wanted to feel more of a sense of
community and and connectivity with
people and to be uplifted and it's like
i didn't want to feel that oppression
anymore and this this movie
jerry and marge it really is it's a
sweet one man i'm telling you guys if
you you sit down watch it with your lady
you're gonna have a good time and um and
and
glad that you spent the 90 minutes
also uh if you haven't seen annette
benning in the grifters
do yourself a favor and watch her and do
some research there watch her in uh
grifters angelica houston john cusack
some great stuff uh how would you uh
rate your performance in the celebrity
softball okay
i would give myself maybe a b-minus i um
i you know adrian beltray came up and he
was trying to
crush it and of course whenever you try
to crush anything you felt it
and he fouled one off and i ran back and
i hit it hit in the heel of my glove and
i dropped it and that was embarrassing i
was catching at the time and then the
second time i thought i if he does that
again i am getting that ball
and he did it again and it went over by
the third base coaches box and i ran my
ass off
i got over there and i and i caught it
to finish the inning so that was good i
also caught a fly ball in left field i
got one base hit a fielder's choice and
then at the end
uh last inning we're down by two runs
and
the umpire i
the ball comes in
i i
leaned back a little bit because it
would have
grazed my chest had i not
i lean back drops down and he calls it a
strike
which gave me the perfect opportunity to
go bananas on the guy you know it's like
i said you know i did the
i did you know a little billy martin and
um
earl weaver job on him i dusted him with
some
with some of dodger stadium's finest
and then threw a bucket of bubble gum at
him and you know it's like
and then jk simmons came in and tried to
you know tried to
get me to calm down a little bit but
i even had people then say man you were
really mad and i go
that's what you thought
wow okay did you uh
who did you want to meet with these
celebrities there you know when
celebrities get together you guys all
act like you know each other or you
should you're all in the same sort of
yeah fraternity man you know i'm a huge
baseball fan so i was
i was
jonesing out on big poppy and beltray
and
uh cece sabbathia was really cool
and the guys i played with sean green
and andre ether former dodgers they were
great they were great and uh it was it
was really fun you know us it was was
great it was uh hunter pence
was is a good dude
uh even though he's a giant
you know at heart i didn't i didn't like
it yeah he got booed i think uh and
deserve it yes absolutely and and jenny
finch wasn't pitching the way jenny
finch pitches right
no i mean uh
i think um
who was it who came up to bat i i think
i think it was uh either uh
i think it was adrian beltray came up to
bat once and and she did one pitch as
she would pitch that ball and i go man
i'm glad i wasn't catching that because
that thing man she is she hums it
uh
are you are you in new orleans
i am i'm in new orleans and
the last time i spoke to you when you
were in new orleans you were doing a
series
yeah
you said it was a one-and-done series
you
said you know my son dies at the end of
course we're not going to do another
year of that season well first of all
thanks for giving away the ending for
those who didn't see the first season
that's really appreciative thank you
very much all right
are you doing a second season of this we
are going to do a second so all of a
sudden uh i'm not the idiot that you
called me
i never called you an idiot you it was
it was inferred that i said oh you got
to do another uh you know season
and then you're the one that said my son
dies at the end
but i never said that on the air did i i
think you did
i mean you should still watch the series
i thought it was really well done your
honor
thank you so so you're going to do
another is that why you're is that the
look here your honor are you on the run
in your honor you know your journalistic
prohibitive questions are really
starting to get in here it's really
really good
i'm not at liberty to just
discuss that it is a highly kept secret
here in the entertainment world
and we keep those you know close to
heart
i respect that
i appreciate that
all right well yes great to talk to you
i'm glad you survived
you too guys i really really miss you
when you come out to la let us know our
friends steve and i are working together
so
please say hello come on we'll have
dinner
how do i find you
you know
i'm at five
you got me you know where i got i know
where to find you i know where to find
you yeah i'll just call will ferrell
he'll tell me where you are
just call wilfred this uh i just want to
say at this this celebrity game yeah
i've at the end of five innings
i was throbbing
my legs felt like dead tree trunks
i have a contusion oh wow look at that i
have a laceration and a hematoma and and
i got hit in the chest
in batting practice by anthony ramos
i mean it's like i was getting lazy and
throwing the ball and just saying how am
i going to pitch tonight you know like
them throwing some spins and things and
he connected with a line drive
from about 25 feet away and
wham right in my upper j i have a big
bruise up here it's it's it's nasty
business take off your shirt let me see
it i'm not gonna take off my shirt oh
you want to see me with my my shirt i
know that i've seen you in your
underwear
yeah see i just it's just what america
wants i can't always give it
i have to be a little circumspect all
right uh great to talk to you stay tuned
ma'am good luck and i hope things are
turned around for you
thank you brian
thanks guys see you later jerry and
marge go large currently on paramount
plus with brian cranston one of the
great actors of our generation and with
annette benning